TENSIONS.
NICK ROBERTSON IS OUT FRONT AND
THIS IS HIS EXCLUSIVE REPORT.
>> Reporter: 27,000 FEET OVER
SCOTLAND.
FLYING AT 275 KNOTS WITH BRITISH
FIGHTER JETS FOR COMPANY.
A U.S. AIR FORCE B-52 BOMBER,
REFUELING ON A FLIGHT FROM SPAIN
BEFORE RETURNING TO A NATO
MISSION, OPERATION ALLIED SKY,
TAKING AIRCRAFT WITHIN SIGHT OF
RUSSIA.
>> PART OF A LARGE SCALE NATO
MISSION INVOLVING MORE THAN 20
NATO MISSIONS FLYING MISSIONS IN
A MESSAGE TO VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> TWO WEEKS AHEAD OF PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S SUMMIT WITH VLADIMIR
PUTIN, A TIMELY STATEMENT OF THE
BACKING OF BIDEN'S DIPLOMACY AND
PUTS NATO'S WINGS IN THE SKIES
CLOSE TO WHERE A BELARUS FIGHTER
JET FORCED A PASSENGER PLANE TO
LAND FORCING A RUSSIAN DISSIDENT
AND HIS GIRLFRIEND OFF RAISING
TENSIONS.
>> I WILL BE MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT PUTIN, MAKING IT CLEAR
WE WILL NOT -- WE WILL NOT STAND
BY AND LET THEM ABUSE THOSE
RIGHTS.
>> THE U.S. AIR FORCE KC TANKER
TOOK OFF FROM SOUTHERN ENGLAND
HALF AN HOUR AHEAD OF THE
REFUEL.
BOTH TANKER AND BOMBER, COLD WAR
ERA AIRCRAFT, OLDER THAN THE AIR
CREW.
BUT WHERE THE TENSIONS CLIMBING,
JUST AS RELEVANT AS WHEN THEY
WERE BUILT.
>> IT IS INTERESTING, I MEAN.
ALL OF THE GENERATIONS OF PILOTS
THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FLY IT.
IT IS UPDATING EVERY ONCE IN A
WHILE.
BUT SHE IS RELIABLE.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT IS WORKING.
SO NO REAL NEED TO CHANGE A
WHOLE LOT.
>> Reporter: THE MISSION,
ACCORDING TO NATO COMMANDERS,
INTENDED TO DEMONSTRATE WHAT
THEY CALL CREDIBILITY OF COMMON
DEFENSE AND ENHANCE READINESS
FOR CAPTAIN TODD BERGLAND.
THIS DAY LIKE OTHERS IN THE
STRATA TANKER, NOTHING LEFT TO
CHANCE.
>> WE HAVE TO BE AT A CERTAIN
PLACE ON TIME WITH THE RIGHT
AMOUNT OF GAS ALL OF THE TIME.
A LITTLE MORE PRESSURE, BUT WE
DO IT SO OFTEN IT IS KIND OF A
HABIT PATTERN.
IT IS OUR PROFESSION.
IT IS JUST WHAT WE DO.
>> Reporter: HOW MUCH BIG NATO
MISSIONS LIKE THIS PHASE PUTIN
IS HARD TO MEASURE.
IN A FEW WEEKS IN GENEVA WHEN
THEY MEET BIDEN WILL